My name is Lewis Kirvan.
Thank you all for coming.
So I don't have my
notes, so I'm going
to do my best because
I can't extend
the displays on this computer,
but I think I'll do OK.
So this presentation.
First of all, let me start off.
I'm Lewis Kirvan.
I'm a research manager at the
Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau.
And I'm supposed to say this,
I am not a representative
of the US government.
I am just myself right now.
I don't know if you
can tell, but I'm not.
The point of this talk is to
help data analysts with words,
and I think words
are actually super
important for data analysts.
If you've ever communicated with
a leader in your organization,
you'll know that a lot of
communication about data
actually flows through words
and that getting good at words
is really going to differentiate
you as a data person.
So the first part
of this talk is
about identifying
situations when you're going
to need more words, right?
So that's part one.
Part two is how to make words a
little bit easier to work with.
So this is focusing
on a couple of things,
but also when you want to
actually generate text,
it's going to give you
some tips, a few tips
to help you generate text.
So that's the
structure of this talk.
Let's get rolling.
All right.
So, chapter one, when
do you need more words?
So this is probably the
most familiar diagram
at the conference.
Everyone's seen this
like way too many times.
It's kind of funny
that I put it in here,
but this document
really captures
a lot about the data
products process, the process
of creating data products.
But I think it leaves out
one really important thing.
You're actually in the
middle of that cycle, right?
And you're doing stuff. Like,
there you are, hands on hips.
So you're in the
middle of the cycle
and you're actually doing
stuff and gaining context
as that cycle sort
of spins around.
Right? you're actually
learning about the data,
learning about the
analysis, learning
about what the goals are.
So you might do some
stuff like this.
You might look at
the application that
generates the data, you might
read a survey instrument,
you might talk to
application users,
you might read the
data documentation,
if you're extremely lucky. You
might read relevant research,
or talk to experts that know
about how and why the data was
generated.
In my opinion, that's all
statistics and data science
too.
That's all important stuff.
And knowing about the
context of your data
is how you don't make
really stupid errors.
So it's super important
and it's something
that I think we don't
emphasize enough, actually.
All right.
So you did your analysis.
You got all this context.
And it's time to communicate.
This is the fun part.
R is really good
at this. Ugh, right?
I don't want to knock
on dashboards too much.
You know, I've built a lot
of dashboards, actually,
in my life.
And, you know, this
dashboard actually
might be fine for someone.
It's just what I got when I
Googled the busiest dashboard
or something like that.
So, you know, I think
that dashboards are fine,
but when you reach for a
communication tool, you know,
you want to think a
little bit before you
grab something that's
very visually dense
or has a lot of moving parts.
So before you
communicate, you want
to think about your audience.
And so the rest of this talk
or the rest of this first part
is going to be a little bit of
how about how you think
about your audience.
You want to bring people
along on your journey.
So, you know, people
need to be brought along.
And a great first question
to ask is, how much of that
context I built up
during my analysis
does my audience share?
You know, if they don't
share the context,
it's going to be a
difficult journey, right?
It's like, how much
do you need to pack
to get that person to
the destination you
want them to go to?
All right.
So I have a couple
of limit cases
here, examples from my own work.
So earlier this year, I
wrote a report to Congress.
It's required by law, and
it's about credit reporting,
consumer complaints.
It's got six charts in it.
Two tables.
Yeah OK, cool.
It started in R Markdown and
it's got 50 pages of context.
All right.
Congress is one limit case.
Congress needs,
like, a lot of stuff.
They need detailed explanations
of all the fields and all
the key terms.
They need to know about the
data collection process.
And they need to know
about, like the law that
governs the data collection
and all that context.
I actually have a JD, so like
that part helped me here,
but Congress
needs a lot of stuff.
So that's like one limit case.
Another limit case is your
immediate team, right?
So a ways back, I made this
dashboard, took me a day.
It's got three charts
in it, six KPIs, less
than paragraph of text.
Beautiful, right? Just me and my
team tracking something.
The labels are kind of terse.
I don't really describe the
KPIs because there our KPIs,
we know what they are.
And you know, like the data
elements are just named what
they are in the system, right?
So this is the other extreme.
You're likely going to be
somewhere in the middle, right?
But these are the
two limit cases.
So I have another
example that I think.
So just to kind of
sum up that idea,
less shared context
means more context,
words, are going to be
in your data product.
More shared contexts means
you can include less context
in your product,
but you should still
document it because
you might forget
other people might work on it.
So it's kind of a seesaw
there. You can go,
does it end up in
the documentation
or does it end up
in the data product?
So here's another example.
Moving from an internal set of
tools to something external.
I like this example because
it's the same data presented
to two different audiences.
So the internal tool is an
interactive Tableau dashboard.
It's got a lot of
charts, dozens of charts.
You know, Tableau
is good for that.
And then the other
example, the field names
correspond to the system names.
It's kind of a typical KPI
type dashboard for your team.
But when this team went to
report out on this stuff,
you know, they started with
this and they kind of just
started to repurpose it
for external communication.
But we were going to actually
share this with banks
and we're sort of assessing
their performance.
And I knew, when I
got sort of thrown
into helping them, that this
document was meant to travel.
It wasn't just going
to go to the person who
works on this stuff every day.
They were going to give
it to their supervisor
and maybe their supervisor
would give it to someone else.
And it probably won't go
to the board of directors,
but it can go travel.
And so the context had to
travel with the document.
So we have this much
simpler version.
So there's only three
simple static charts.
One kind of gives you a time
series of your performance,
one gives you your
average or each one
gives you your average, and then
compares you against your peers
and against some sort
of overall performance.
So that's pretty nice.
Some of the charts from
the internal dashboard
are actually sentences
and paragraphs now.
So the names are all also
defined in an introduction.
You know, a sentence
is actually if you just
like tell someone
what the chart means,
that's actually denser
than a chart, right?
So in some places where
you want to do that stuff.
I also included different
text depending on thresholds
and other stuff, right?
So some of these
sentences and paragraphs
didn't really apply to
some of these companies.
And so we threshold
at it and they just
don't appear in the document.
So it doesn't like bloat
and bloat and bloat.
So that's an example of moving
from internal to external.
Summarize this with
some key factors.
The biggest one is
external, right?
If they're outside
your org, they
don't have any of
your context likely.
But even within your
org, you can think
about levels of externality,
right? There's your immediate team,
and then there's
concentric circles.
And as you kind move
further away from your team,
you need to be adding
more context in.
Another key factor
is if you're kind
of dealing with a less
technical audience.
Less technical audiences
mean you can't use shortcuts
that you might use when
you're communicating
with a technical audience.
Like you're not just
going to present an ROC
curve to your
executive and say, hey,
look, my model is
really good, look,
because they're not
going to get that right.
So you have to think
about adding more context
in for those folks.
Decision makers are important
because they actually
need context to trust
what you're telling them.
If they don't have
appropriate context,
they're not going to
trust you and they're
going to reject your findings
even if you're right.
Right? You can pound
the table all you want,
but they need enough
context to trust you.
And I've had this happen to me.
It's pretty disappointing,
honestly, when you're like,
look, it works, it's great.
And they're like, I don't
know what this is even. Right?
So you have to give them
that appropriate context.
Time crunched is actually kind
of counterintuitive in a way,
right?
Time crunched
people you want to give
them as little as possible
in some ways, but
you're only going
to get them one time, right?
So those time crunched
people have one shot.
And if they don't walk away
with the context that's
necessary to understand
this, they'll
either misinterpret
it, not interpret it,
or forget about it.
Right? So those time crunched
people are important too.
So those are some
key factors when
thinking about this question
of like, what should I build?
How much context do I need
to put in it for my audience?
All right.
Chapter two, how to make
words a little bit easier.
All right, I'm done, guys.
That's it.
Actually, now I'm done.
Not really.
I actually have some tips.
So my tips are just three
kind of simple things.
Use some templates, use design
resources, and then partner up.
All right, let's start
with the first one.
So the context here is
you're generating text.
If you've ever generated a
document with a lot of text.
What happens is your
environment just
gets littered with variables.
There's all kinds of
different variables.
Some of these documents
I put together,
you know, ten, 15
pages, you know,
you've computed 10
different means.
They all have different names.
And when you make a mistake,
debugging is annoying and hard.
And so what you can
do is actually add
a language engine
that will allow
you to put templates in
your R Markdown document
and then fill them with data.
This is a really simple
language, really simple
function.
You can just add at the
top of your Markdown file,
it's a knitr engine, here,
and this works in quarto.
I just did it right.
That works.
So you add this, this
is using whisker,
which uses
mustache templates.
I'll talk about that
in just one second.
Options code.
That's just the stuff
that's in your code block.
So you put your template
in there and then,
as an argument, you
supply some data,
and then it will render and
make something nice for you.
You could do it with glue, too.
So here it is with glue.
Basically the same function.
You need more stuff for glue.
This would be quite a bit
longer if I were to really
put this together for glue.
But just so you can see,
the basics are the same.
This still works, but
there's stuff you want to do.
All right.
So here's an example
of just that concept
of taking your namespace or
using a list as a namespace
so that you don't basically end
up cluttering your namespace.
So I'm generating
one sentence here
and there's one, two, three,
four, five or so six variables.
There's a bunch of variables
just for one sentence.
Right?
and what I like to do is
when I have a document
with some structure in it, like
a section, I'll have a list
and I'll pack all the variables
for that section into the list
that's named the same.
And then my environment
stays like relatively pretty.
Debugging gets easier,
and my mental load
as a developer doesn't sort of
go haywire completely, right?
And so then when
you go to do this,
it's actually pretty simple.
You have right here, this
is a mustache template,
a really simple one.
Mustache is great.
It has some other it's
a logicless template.
So it's very-- it's almost
like Markdown in a way,
but you can add some
basically data dependent stuff
that will make stuff
appear or not appear.
There's a few other nice little
features, but it kind of just
works.
So there's the
data filling it in.
The sentence now exists
and there's a glue version.
You need some post-processing
on glue to make it
not have quotes and stuff.
The real function
I use is longer,
but I didn't want to go
into all that detail.
So that's tip one.
I think it's pretty helpful.
And you know, if you do more
of this stuff, especially
when you're generating a lot
of text, it's super helpful.
Tip two, use existing
design resources.
Design is super duper important
when you're making a document
that you want people to read.
You need consistency
and you need signposting
to make the document useful.
And I am kind of took a weird
path to being a researcher
and data analyst.
I've got a degree in African
history and a JD.
So I spent like 30
years trying to make
other kinds of good documents.
So some of this stuff
is natural to me,
but I think it should be
more natural to data analysts
as well.
So someone at your
org has probably
thought about those issues, that
signposting, that consistency,
and they have resources for
you, so you should steal them
basically.
So it's almost as
easy as this, right?
So you have in your
YAML a reference stock.
The actual package comes
with a reference doc.
You look at that reference,
it shows you all the styles
that you need and actually quarto has
some surprisingly good actually
documentation on
where it styles if you
need some documentation on it.
And so then you can
either adjust the styles
yourself or you can
actually copy and paste
styles between documents.
So if you have a nice
reference document,
you can go ahead and use that.
Great. So this is what it
looks like when you use it.
It's just like any other pandoc
kind of colon braces thing.
You put it in there and
then the style gets applied.
This is actually a style from
my org's work DOCX template
that we use or one of our
DOCX templates that we use.
And I have no idea how to make
that pull quote in Word.
I don't want to know.
That sounds like
a pain in my butt.
So instead I use I
leverage someone else who
did know how to use that.
And in my documents I
can use this feature.
All right.
This is cheating because
it's not really about words.
But it saved me so much time
over the course of my career
that I just have to say it.
You should if you don't have
one of these at your org,
a minimal, minimal package to
package up your design system
is super helpful.
So you can put all your
organization's colors
into an easy to access list.
This is going to save
you all that time.
Looking up hexes and
remembering hexes.
Amazing. And then
just a minimal ggplot theme
that gets you most of the way.
If you have one of
these at your org, like,
people will love you.
You know, I maintain
the one at my org now
and people love
me just for that.
And I didn't even create it.
So this is like
something you should do.
And it'll save you
enough time that you
can spend more time focusing
on writing and polishing
your writing.
All right.
My tip number 3 is sort
of a general life tip.
Ask for help and
partner up when you can.
It really applies
a lot with writing.
Writing is really hard.
Writing is really hard
for analytical people
because you have high
expectations for your audience.
You shouldn't have high
And a writer can help
you with that, right?
They can help you lots of stuff.
They can help you with grammar.
The grammar for language.
Oh, good.
One, one, one
laugh for my dad joke.
Anyways, they can give
you an outside opinion,
like, does this make
any sense at all?
And they can help you
think about your audience.